hold the bus and wait till we tell you
what's been going on in Scotland
Nicholas sturgeon's decision to step
down as first Minister and leader of the
SNP took pretty much everyone bar her by
surprise now she remains in post until
the end of March whilst the party she's
LED since 2014 marks out who best to
fill her shoes and let's just say the
candidates haven't exactly been playing
nicely when you were a transport
Minister the trains were never on time
when you're a Justice Minister the
police were strained to Breaking Point
and now as health Minister we've got
record high waiting times in the first
week of your campaign you had people who
voted yes leave your campaign as I've
just said the mud slinging on this needs
to stop and I'm calling for calm
accusations of homophobia Blue on Blue
or should that be yellow on yellow
attacks over the party's record in
government briefing and counter briefing
and they all have to work with each
other afterwards and one of their
ultimate goal not the job of first
Minister but being the politician that
secures Scotland its independence or
with the departure of the most
successful politician in Scotland's
history is this the beginning of the end
of the snp's dominance of Scottish
politics
I'm Neil Patterson and this is the Sky
News deal
he's been very busy of late our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillis but he's
dragged himself away from following the
candidates Kate Forbes Ash Regan and
Hamza Yusuf at Connor we will go through
their separate pictures in just a moment
but first explain the process that the
SNP follows you know we've had a few
leadership contests over the past few
years yeah I think it's worth
reiterating and remembering that
actually yes the labor party the
Conservative Party politics across the
UK has been turbulent in terms of
leaders coming and going but actually
the SNP has not had a leadership contest
for almost 20 years so the ballot itself
opens on Monday the 13th that is when
the roughly 100 000 SNP members will
begin that process we'll begin their
proper deliberations as to who they want
to succeed Nicola sturgeon as leader of
the party but of course essentially
electing the next first minister of
Scotland that ballot will remain open
for a number of weeks and then come to
its final Crescendo the peak in this
contest on the 27th of March when we
will discover who the next uh SMP leader
is and of course ultimately the next
first minister of Scotland walk us
through the three candidates then well
known in Scotland perhaps not as much so
elsewhere and we should probably start
with Hamza Yusuf the health secretary
I'm gonna say that if you are looking
for a continuity candidate then it would
probably be him
I think that's what humsley youth have
would would say as well he has had many
senior positions within the Scottish
government over the course of the last
10 years or so he was a junior Minister
for Europe back in the day progressed on
to transport Minister then became
Justice secretary and laterally and most
recently is now the health secretary in
charge of an NHS that is in crisis he
has come under sustained criticism
sustained scrutiny over his handling of
the Health Service in Scotland so I
think it is fair to say he is favored uh
among the senior figures uh in terms of
the SMP hierarchy to continue on that
mantle that Nicola sturgeon has built I
mean Hamza Yusuf himself you know the
the backstory it's remarkable you know
youngest MSP uh first non-white first
Muslim minister in Hollywood
I have to say though looking forward if
he sticks to Nicola sturgeon's strategy
plans you know to the letter he's going
nowhere so what is he going to do that's
different there's the school of thought
within the SNP that love what Nicholas
sturgeon uh carved and what she built
and then there's the other school of
thought who think well actually the
issues in the last couple of months that
arguably led to the downfall of Nicholas
sturgeon namely the gender reforms
that's got the Scottish Parliament voted
through just before Christmas which
essentially is a historic piece of
legislation that makes it easier for
people to change their legally
recognized gender it's a system of
self-identification it's unlike the rest
of the UK and Hamza Yusuf has been clear
that he was for that policy he voted for
that policy he would continue to push
that policy and the Westminster
government has been in a situation where
it doesn't believe potentially that that
legislation is legal and it is
attempting to block it at the moment
Hamza Yusuf has been clear that he would
go through with a legal Challenge on
that because he says this is about much
more than the gender policy itself what
you should not oppose what you cannot
oppose is that it should be the Scottish
people's right to choose that right of
when to have a referendum should be ours
should be made by the Scottish
Parliament by the Scottish people not by
Boris Johnson or the Westminster
government
second of all of course the key issue of
Independence he has been clear that he
would not use the next general election
as essentially de facto Independence
referendum that's a big break from the
sturgeon policy agenda it is but I think
there's a recognition that Independence
is not going to happen anytime soon in
Scotland the way things are at the
moment I think that was what Nicholas
sturgeon realized quite clearly as well
and was one of the reasons why she had
to go well let's talk about Ash Regan
then you'll need to tell us a little bit
more about her she is perhaps the least
well-known of the candidates but if you
want a defender of the independence
faith I mean you've got it in her yeah I
think it's fair to say that you know it
harms the use of might not be known
south of Gretna Green asked Reagan might
not be known outside of the Hollywood
Bubble at all uh got into politics just
a number of years ago and has not been a
high profile politician until
she took a stance on that gender reform
policy that we discussed a second ago
she was in Nicola sturgeon's government
as a minister and she said she could not
vote for that and she was the first SMP
Minister since the SMP came to power in
2007 to resign from the government on a
matter of policy the FID was not in the
manifesto so just need to be very clear
about that it was not in the manifesto
and I actually was one of many s p
colleagues who signed an open letter to
the newspapers in 2019 about these exact
issues so I think it's not credible to
say that my views on this subject were
not well known I mean that's incredible
the SNP have have long been known as the
steadiest of ships Whenever there arose
Whenever there are there are arguments
outside of this leadership campaign of
which more later they tend to take place
behind closed doors absolutely this is a
party of discipline it's a party of
unity and the gender around the gender
debate the toxic debate that came with
that has caused split it's caused
divisions among colleagues in a really
open and public way that the SNP has not
been famous for over the course of the
last couple of years and a face of that
has been Ash Regan and she would not
challenge the Westminster legal route
that humza Yusuf would well let's talk
then about the perhaps the strongest
Challenger to Hamza Yusuf Kate Forbes
the finance secretary and and again this
will be a name that some people in the
South recognize perhaps because of our
stance over same-sex marriage explain
that one yeah so Kate Forbes came into
politics a couple of years ago she
became the finance secretary in charge
of Scotland's uh finances essentially
overnight and has been seen ever since
as a rising star within the SMP ranks
she went off on maternity leave last
year
um her baby's about six months old now
and this contest has forced her back
earlier than than she was predicting but
she's been clear since she came back and
the first day that she appeared on this
campaign Trail to put her name forward
for the next SMP leader for the next
first minister of Scotland and she told
some of my colleagues here in Scotland
that she would not have voted for equal
marriage had she been an MSP at the time
back in 2014 and then when I sat down
with her just a couple of hours after
that I questioned her about her
religious beliefs because she says
religion is the reason she wouldn't have
voted for same-sex marriage is it
correct
for people to have children before
marriage
early up to date
what's your view is it is it correct for
children for for people across Scotland
to have children outside of marriage um
it's it's not it's something that I
would
um seek to avoid for me personally but
it doesn't fuss me doesn't put me up no
down and the choices that other people
make is it right or is it is it right or
is it wrong in terms of my faith my
faith would say that children well if
there's Sexes for for marriage and
that's the approach that I would
practice
so that created a huge storm and set her
back she lost a lot of high-profile
supporters within the SMP MPS msps north
of the Border who had publicly backed
her u-turned on that switch sides to
Hamza Yusuf instead and that created a
big issue yeah sure sure but I really
cannot get my head around that for so
long now the SNP have styled themselves
as incredibly socially Progressive and
there is a chance a very real chance
that the next leader of the SNP the next
first minister of Scotland will be
someone who does not believe in same-sex
marriage and and who presumably believes
an awful lot of other things that would
not sit particularly well with the
majority of Grassroots SNP supporters
she would say and she has done over the
course of this campaign as she tried to
reset following those very highly
controversial comments at the start that
she can have her own personal views she
has set Scottish budgets and she hasn't
brought Prejudice into the mix when it
comes to that and she would govern in
the same way that she has governed the
finances as well but during the course
of the last week or so there has been a
number of televised debates and they
have been incredibly ugly we heard from
Kate Forbes attacking Hamza Yusuf let's
just remember that Cape Forbes albeit
she's been on maternities but she is a
current serving Finance secretary at the
moment she was on television attacking
Hamza Yusuf the current serving Health
secretary both in the same government
both in the same party essentially
throwing comes the use of under the bus
on National Television you've had a
number of jobs in government when you
were a transport Minister the trains
were never on time when you're a Justice
Minister the police were strained to
bake breaking point and now as health
Minister we've got record high waiting
times what makes you think you can do a
better job as first Minister this was a
public spot and essentially cabinet
ministers suggesting that colleagues are
unfit to govern questioning their
competence and the question that came
from that is how on Earth does the party
come back from that after all of this
and that's a huge question that kind of
lingers and is of grave concern for many
in the party I mean on a personal level
away from the the kind of the public
policy and stuff what what do you make
of the three of them I mean there there
have been light-hearted moments tons of
Yusuf said to me a couple of weeks ago
that he feels that he's uh been
interviewed more and seen me more than
his wife over the course of this
campaign
how many questions he's been Fielding
Kate Forbes she was very relaxed almost
too relaxed actually following that
pretty car crash interview where she
talked about uh children outside of
marriage afterwards I don't think she
quite maybe she did realize that what
she was saying and the reaction that
that was going to trigger across the the
SMP movement Ash Regan I think she's
different to the race I don't know her
as much for the reasons that we've
already discussed um and heart interview
was slightly different in a way that
she couldn't really answer questions I
got the impression and this is a
personal reflection uh that there was
maybe a suggestion she was potentially
trying to make some things up on the
hoof
[Music]
say that the SNP are the dominant force
in Scottish politics would be an
understatement and with Nicholas
sturgeon off to pursue other
opportunities whoever takes over some
very big shoes to fill and a support
base Whose desire for Independence
asafp cannot be ignored strathcart
University's election expert professor
John Curtis is here and John let's start
with those who actually get to choose
the next first Minister SNP members how
are they feeling about the candidates
well we've only so far had one poll of
SNP members themselves and it was a
relatively small poll of around 500
people but uh headline number one from
that was an awful lot of them hunt made
up their minds one in three said uh they
didn't know how they were going to vote
but amongst that group homeser yourself
was narrowly ahead of Cape Forbes by 31
to 25 with Ash Reagan as in all the
other polling well behind at uh around
the 10 Mark or so so uh the the truth is
that certainly looks as though it's a
two-horse race and I think the honest
truth is as we speak we're not entirely
sure which of them is going to win so so
then if we if we kind of cast our eyes
slightly further and talk about the
population in general I mean clearly the
SNP have been you know dominant in
Scottish politics for a long time that
in part I would say it was has been to
do with the person at the top Alex
Hammond and then of course at Nicholas
sturgeon I mean with with the public at
large does it still stack up pretty much
the same kind of a two-horse race it is
a two horse race as far as the German
public is concerned but it's a two-horse
race with a rather different character
in some senses uh there is a feature of
this election which is very similar to
that of the conservative leadership
election last year if the general public
had been voting last year then Rishi
sunak will almost undarty one but so far
as members were concerned it was less
trust well I've already told you that Mr
Yusuf is ahead amongst the members so
far as we know and indeed it now looks
as though on the more recent pollings
that he's at least neck and neck with
Miss Forbes amongst SMP voters indeed
one poll puts in my head but when it
comes to the general public uh all of
the polling so far has suggested that
Miss Forbes ahead but of course that
illustrates her problem where which is
that it might be question mark that she
might be better able than Mr Yusuf to
appeal to those who are not currently
SMP supporters to those who are not yet
currently minded to vote Yes to
Independence but in order to get the
opportunity to be able to do that you
first of all needs to be able to win
this election which is amongst the
hundred thousand or so people that are
members of the SMP so at the moment
she's got to find a way of appealing to
that group if she's going to be able to
capitalize upon what might be
potentially a greater ability to reach
out more widely to the Scottish public
let me explain this one to me if you can
why has it proved so difficult for
Nicholas sturgeon and and will prove
difficult for for the candidates whoever
is successful to to get that persistent
majority support for Independence I was
I was in Scotland covering the
referendum I went back up in I think
around about March of 2014 when I think
they were polling in the low 30s by the
end of that campaign they'd gotten all
the way to 45 we're almost a decade on
that's an awful lot of young people
enthused by the campaign who have now
got the opportunity to vote I mean why
have we not got above that 50 and stayed
there well the truth is I mean support
for Independents since about 2019 has
tended
to oscillate around the 49 Mark and
there is no data a big challenge facing
the next SMP leader is simply to get the
debate started to get people talking
about it you know at the end of the day
Scotland is not going to vote for
Independence or not because of people's
views about the grr bill or indeed about
gay marriage these are not going to be
Central issues in the campaign the
lesson of 2014 is that the central issue
that is most likely to determine how
people will vote in any Independence
referendum is the issue of economics and
that is the issue that so far at least
the candidates have not released any
degree of detail uh indicated their
standpoint just a word from you John
then on on Nicholas sturgeon herself and
you know the the future of the party
that she leaves behind means certainly
one of the most successful intellectual
times politicians that we have ever seen
in this country Titanic to the
independence movement I mean I I keep
hearing people particularly on the
unionist side suggesting that this is
the point at which the snp's dominance
in Scottish politics Will begin to end
what's your review well the answer is
that there are the downside risks to the
SMP are clear
um they're essentially twofold one is
that voters Will Come Away with the
impression that the party is divided and
that uh you know the source that will
undoubtedly be exposed during this
Leisure campaign already have been
exposed that they will not be healed and
number two uh that whoever is the
leaders we've been discussing fails
indeed to be able to develop a case for
Independence in the wake of that support
for Independence goes down the the
Electoral fortunes of the SMP these days
are very very intimately tied up with
level support for Independence that's a
risk there is no doubt about it but it's
not guaranteed and one has to say that
so far it is for example the theories
that we're out there that now it's
obvious that the labor party or at least
their party's got a good chance of
winning the UK election that support for
Independence would go down well no
immediate sign of of that being true we
may well I think certainly discover some
bumpiness in support for the SMP and for
Independence during the course of this
leadership debate I think there's
already some signs of that in the polls
but frankly we won't know what the
Fallout is until we know who is one and
with what Authority at Professor Cutters
thank you um back to you Connor no of
course I I cannot believe for a second
that Nicholas sturgeon would have
overtly endorsed any of the candidates
you just simply don't do that when
you're in the position that she's in but
if she hadn't perhaps you know given us
a nod in the wink
hello to be totally Frank however
however I think that there is a sense
within the campaign and when I say the
campaign I'm talking the ash Regan and
the cape Forbes campaign that Humsa
Yusuf is being geared up and this is
their point of view is being engineered
is being coronated into this position to
take over from Nicholas sturgeon uh in
terms of the high profile support and
attempts are being made to ostracize
Cape Forbes as part of this and so this
is a difficult position for the SMP it's
a difficult position for the first
Minister who can't have a view in this
but is the headquarters is the machine
the PowerHouse that is the SMP
playing a part in this campaign not in a
direct way but in a very subtle way that
plays into the hands of one candidate
over another
Nicholas sturgeon claiming as recently
as 2021 that the SMP was the most United
of all the parties in Scotland at the
end of it this it will not be so whoever
takes over has An Almighty job on their
hands don't they not just to push for
Independence not just to get Scotland
back on an even Keel but actually
reunite the Scottish national party
whoever wins this contest not only has a
mountain to climb when it comes to
policy has the challenges of trying to
deliver Independence for a movement who
are itching at the bit to try and
achieve their mission over the course of
decades and Decades of work but as you
said this is a party that is now
synonymous over the course of the last
couple of weeks for infighting for
bitter disputes public spats and
Nicholas sturgeon will be watching this
unravel in front of her eyes from behind
the couch and probably never in a
million years we'd have realized that
this is what would have triggered on but
many many commentators here in Scotland
say this is part of Nicholas sturgeon's
doing because in a way that Alex salmond
geared Nicholas sturgeon up to be the
natural successor Nicholas sturgeon has
not done that and that has led
to three contenders getting in the mix
here and for the very public spats that
there have been and actually it's the
party and it's the independence movement
that will suffer and could have long
long lasting impacts that push
Independence even further into the
distance
[Music]
my thanks to Connor gillex sister John
Curtis and of course to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Neil Patterson this episode was produced
by Rosie Gillett with Alex Eden our
editor is Phillip
[Music]